can you break down what you mean by
dismantling the bureaucracy because it
sounds good within Poli so so so it's
like the you know if you have like an
eight hited Hydra and you cut off one of
the heads it grows right back that's
what that's the model of incremental
reform that's you know Ronda sandis when
he says I want to fire Christopher Ray
at the FBI that's the way I view it is
cosmetic change what you're saying is
Christopher Ray is one guy christop is
like lit guys that are going to keep
35,000 35,000 other guys so so I mean
shut down the
so so the institution known as the
Federal Bureau of Investigation what I
call failed Bureau of Investigation
because I think it has failed to even
carry out its basic law enforcement
functions on issues ranging from child
trafficking to defal
epidemic actually the right answer is to
shut it down so there's always the risk
when you're taking well I'll tell you
what the mechanics look like but there's
always the risk you're going to take
some risk one risk is you don't cut
enough fat the other is that you take
you cut so much that you also cut some
muscle you can't say no I'm going to cut
all of it in just the precise amount
because if you're bringing a chainsaw
that's not a plan yeah my where I'm
different than most people is I am
willing to take the risk of cutting so
much that we cut some muscle but I
believe the right approach will then to
be regrow in a precise manner that which
you overcut rather than to take the risk
of not cutting enough which I think is
an illusion in some ways the worst of
all worlds which gives the people the
sense that something happened without
actually anything of me but isn't that
our risk what's that that's our risk
that's the one that's what's happening
right now what I'm saying is that's not
your risk it's the people's risk but
that's what I mean well I'm I'm I'm
saying us as the people right us as us
as the people say I'm the politician
willing to take the risk I'm like yo
you're taking the risk on my behalf
security I guess that's rooted in the
theory that he doesn't think they're
acting for the people yeah they're not
I'm just VI myself I'm volunteering to
represent B what's so bad with the FBI
so I think the FBI has been rotten since
its Inception yeah and it was it was the
embodiment of the managerial class so J
G Hoover built himself in his
institution to be effectively insulated
from any form of public
accountability he uh I don't know if you
guys here's a book I would actually
really recommend my wife has read it
about anything so there's a book called
Gman I would read it okay it's not some
right-wing screed I promise it's it's
like a Yale historian for all knows the
Lefty for all I know is talks about the
history of the J can I just Define one
thing for everybody listening or
watching right now we're going to use
the term Manago manage Euro class for
the rest of the podcast this is
essentially the middleman between what
the people want and the politicians that
are serving them or the workers of a
company and who the I would call I call
yeah exactly that sounds good that
sounds good princip or own the so there
there's this system the committee class
the committee class the managerial class
whatever it is but these people aren't
necessarily working yep for the company
they might not in the ter in Black Rock
they are but they're not working for the
government necessarily they are it's a
separate breed of middle of middle
management bureaucrats it's like the
equivalent of who sits in between the
student and the tenur professor at the
university is is the dean of in politics
how does this present itself is it
politicians three letter agencies the
three-letter agencies got it that's what
we're talking about FBI SEC ATF CDC
Department of Education TSA DEA DEA what
about companies what about uh you know
what about um Boeing or uh it gets it
gets so so the way I view companies is
they View these unaccountable nodes as
their vehicles for capture and the node
is the
politician the Agy the agency the agency
so that's where power gets concentrated
it's in an unaccountable place then it's
just about capturing it so you are
talking about actually cutting people at
these agencies I'm talking about
shutting the whole agency shutting the
whole agency down because the idea isar
to like how people said defund the
police they complained of how the police
system has been running all this time so
now they're like I think this legiate so
so so my view is on argument on the FBI
on the FBI's case there's 35,000
employees at the FBI and by there the
same FBI that 60 years ago was
incorrectly collecting tapes of Martin
Luther King and threatening him over to
commit suicide over you know his his
affronts or whatever that today is going
after he saw he saw the tattoo [__]
been collecting information this whole
time I like the tattoo it made that
today is actually now going after I
believe political opponents who have
have itical persuasion that the
benevolent dictators inside the three
ler agency have decided need to be
quashed just like they decided he needed
to be quashed so it's not a partisan
point I'm making but so that 35,000
employees at the FBI 20,000 of them are
the back office
bureaucrats that are the classic typical
managerial class when I say shut down
the FBI those 20,000 are going home and
finding honest work whatever it is and
by the way we happen to live in a moment
where most businesses have more job
openings than there are people looking
for work in this country so maybe we can
kill two birds with one stone but either
way they're going home the 15,000 cops
on the front lines investigative agents
we will move them to say the US Marshals
which I mean everything I'm naming they
each have their own problems but they're
not as an institution has not suffered
the same level of rot that the FBI has
yeah and and and the yes and the US
Marshals has been far more effective
than the FBI in going after child sex
trafficking rings and you know you can
even talk about the DA has a lot of its
faults but sooner I would move them to
the DEA than than keep at the FBI to go
after the fentel epidemic there's a
financial crimes enforcement Network at
the US Treasury to go after the future
sbfs or the ftxs or the financial
fraudsters of the world the remaining
15,000 move them that's shutting down
the FBI looks like how do you decide
who's who how do you decide 15,000 good
20,000 bad well the the the 15,000 are
investigative agents like that are not
sort of police off they're like the
equivalent of the cops actually so so we
we use that Frontline talent but depu by
at least a bureaucracy that has not been
corrupted in the same way that the
current FBI has and the current FBI
makes it pretty nakedly transparent it's
still for God's sake the J Edgar Hoover
building it's the name of the building
they're celebrating the guy's Legacy
today so I would say shut it down and
and I'm different than every other
Republican in that regard but I think
that that's actually the correct answer
but this is this is this is why we need
like context for these conversations
saying shut down the FBI is such like a
volatile headline that when I see that
and I'm like what a ridiculous notion
like what is he saying is trying to
Trump up some [__] you you know my
wife is my wife is the best friend cuz
she's she's not a politicized person
she's brilliant person she thought this
is she initially thought this crazy talk
she's actually the one who found Gman
she's just like all right I know my
husband he's saying some stuff that
people say sounding crazy but let me
just form my own opinion and so she's
actually the one that included me into
into Gman which is I don't think anybody
who reads that book will come out
believing anything other than not
they're going to think I'm going to say
it's crazy they think the stat they will
you will agree with me the status quo is
what's crazy
and it's it's crazy that we ever allowed
for the creation of an institution like
this that was this insulated from
account your umbrella is not shut down
the FBI your umbrella is shut down any
actor agency single person that
interrupts what the people want and how
that is executed exactly and here's the
thing I can't take credit for that but
real quick just because our founding
fathers said it in motion so one say is
there's three branches of government in
the United States real quick so we don't
move off cuz I don't want people to to
miss this cuz I think it's important
point you thought the FBI was being used
to I guess remove certain potential
nominees or to tarnish their image to to
interfere with election processes is
that fair among other things not just
give one example so people can digest so
I the FBI I I believe yeah I believe the
FBI played a role I'm saying the decid
we don't have all the facts but based on
what we know talking about Biden laptop
well I I I believe the FBI even played a
role in instigating January 6 okay so
perfect example we can talk about both
of those things but just so I people
just just so people don't miss both and
I want to get back to that but just so
people don't miss miss the point the
point is if the
FBI itself or is being used to interrupt
what the people want in this situation
it is a nominee and if they're
tarnishing the image of that nominee now
the people don't get the elected
official that they actually desire B on
false pretenses exactly and then that is
the problem with the agerial class in
the same way it's a problem with black
rock with your investment one of many
problems with man CL I think I think
that is a very digestible way of going
so it's not even the FBI as the problem
it's not the letters it's the fact that
this organization has been used as a
weapon to remove the freedom of the
people to elect a person that they feel
represents exactly with imp this and if
those elected representatives pass bad
laws well that's your fault as Thomas
Jefferson says that's your account yeah
be Thomas Jefferson great quote I'm
going to botch it but but basically he
says the people deserve the government
they vote for and govern sucks you voted
for it and listen and he's the guy who
wrote the Declaration of Independence by
the way theep state is essentially just
the manager who can act without the
president and the Deep State and it's
and it's not in a critical sense I'm
just off a descriptive sense the Deep
State effectively says yes the people
are going to get the government they
vote for and it's going to suck because
people are idiots idiot
and they cannot be trusted and and
they're it's it's bad for them and so we
need to make sure that people don't get
the government they they vote for
because that's going to be a pretty
shitty government and they better get
actually one that actually allows them
to have what's better for them even
though they don't know let's use
managerial class instead of deep say
just so I just want because this this is
like the managerial class it's I think a
really important point that I think
would resonate with people because the
average person I feel right now is so
disillusioned with government I think
that's why you see like people going how
is Biden president how is there nobody
else that's out there what the hell is
going on and I think that's why Bernie
and I think that's why Trump were these
two figures that got so much support
because they were both seen as Outsiders
to the system so people are
disillusioned with the system and the
system is the [__] managerial class
that makes me feel like the people that
I am voting for do not represent my
actual interest or that feeling is
grounded
truth it's not just a feeling accurate
perception of what is true like what you
said right there with the FBI if the FBI
if right if the FBI is limiting my
options of people to vote for and I'm
just voting for the lesser of two evils
which I think both sides end up kind of
doing you're voting for in your brain
the lesser of two evils you have limited
my option to vote for the person that I
truly want to represent me so that is
the so if the FBI or if any other
three-letter agency or anything else is
restricting my representation I agree we
should have some way of of you know
taking a jackhammer to that system I
don't know what it is but to me that is
a way more digestible yes yeah does that
make sense did you guys know initially
when he said question is do we need some
version of a managerial class are you
here to abolish it or recreate it I
think I think that we go through these
Cycles in history right but I think that
we live in one of the moments where the
only way you're going
to gonna slay the Leviathan and I use
that term the leviathan's Thomas Hobbs I
mean this is what the stuff I'm
describing by the way is like these are
not original observations they this has
been a struggle for most of human
history yeah but it's what Thomas Hobs
called the Leviathan is what we're
calling the machine or the managerial
class we live in a moment right now
where it is imposs I believe it is
impossible to incrementally pick around
the edges of it MH I think right now the
only available effective option mhm is
to take the risk and probably there's
going to be some cost involved probably
there's going to be some negatives that
come out of it I'll be the first to
acknowledge that but on net undoubtedly
the right thing to do is nonetheless to
come in and break the hell out of the
glass and acknowledge there's going to
be
some inconvenience that may come from
that and a trans frictional transitional
CA but absent our willingness to do that
it just isn't otherwise going to happen
happen and so
that that's up to the people who come
next it's going to happen again and then
we got to break it again exactly and so
that becomes that becomes that iterative
cycle but hopefully it never gets to the
place where the scale of the wreckage
needs to be what it is
now but the question is that's up to
every one of us makes our own unique
contribution and imprint this is the
imprint that the next leader successful
leader of our country I think needs to
make okay and then and then it's up to
the guy who comes after and and to the
people who come after and what we decide
and iteratively how we respond to that
because then inevitably there's going to
be some Calamity it's going to be how
did how did we allow that to happen yeah
and then we're going to actually we're
going to accept a tradeoff that's in the
other direction of that Calamity aren't
we smart enough to have prevented this
well it was really self-governance that
got us there so this becomes I mean this
is The Human Experience right this is
iteratively the struggle that like human
history is all about consolidates but
this is right now where we are in my Bel
yeah it sounds good it's just hard to
run on that because think about the
20,000 people and their families that
are let go of just that one agency and
then the 30,000 here and the 50,000 I've
had I've had people in the rooms with me
be like oh like my my uncle or my son is
working in this agency and I answer them
honestly which is that I don't think and
it sounds like a crude thing to say but
it's the truth I don't think that the
job of the federal government is or
should be to provide employment
opportunity I just don't I think the Rob
federal government is represent interest
of the people now it turns out by God
the one of the main things limiting our
economic growth right now is literally
if you're a small business or even a
large business the number one thing
that's stopping you from expanding right
now is literally finding people to staff
your open positions so that's the
country we live in right now and one
which we have the massive problem that
we do not to mention the cost of this I
mean it's not cost free from a taxpayer
perspective when we're $34 trillion in
the whole as a nation as well in
national
debt to say that I I have sympathy for
many of the individuals involved cuz
said it's not one of these as like a
culprit and evil
person but the right thing to do for the
nation is for those for public service
to be about public service and not about
guarantor of employment opportunity and
that we need to live in a thriving
country in which those people find
employment opportunity elsewhere in an
economy that right now happens to be
hungering for more people to fill open
roles of employment and so you're right
you're right Mak a political point you
that may not win you vote friends
amongst those voters and that's true
I've also had many people who have come
up and said I've worked in these
bureaucracies and I understand that I
would lose my job but you're right I've
seen it and I and I agree with you which
is also heartening as well I'm not
saying that's everybody but I think that
that's for people who have been on the
inside what I'm saying is not that
foreign to process and in anyway the
piece about shutting it down is like I
think if you do it in an orderly way
right so I want to lay off 75% of the
federal bureaucracy over the course of
the first term so we'd stage it over
four years we're not doing all of that
on day one the first four agencies I had
said I would shut down would be FBI ATF
CDC and US Department of Education we've
got I if I may say so myself I would
like to think relatively orderly plans
for carrying this out please explain
Department of Education that's another
one that I heard your take and it was
really smart but I think to people it's
like what the [__] are you talking about
so it's just so jarring and I'm sure for
you because you've probably read so much
about this you've thought so much about
this you've been in the think tank
meetings with your people where you're
like how can we execute this incredibly
difficult task it probably seems like an
absolute no-brainer right and one of the
tricky things about being a politician
which I'm sure you've learned which is
different than being a CEO is when it
comes to a CEO and I'm subscribing to
you I'm going I want to work for this
guy believe in this guy I don't even
need you to convince me I trust that you
know what we're going to do and maybe
I'll go hey I think this is a good way
to do it and then I could influence your
opinion but when it comes to being a
politician you're going to make this
change and you need to commit me that
this change is in my best interest and
when I just hear shut down the because
you're the boss actually that's what it
is exactly people people lose that sense
one of the beauties of this Iowa caucus
process I did more events than all the
other candidates combined yeah which is
I realized actually through the process
what this was actually about if if the
if this process of like Iowa going first
through this caucus system is about
something it's actually about instilling
humility into the candidat that's really
what it's about is you otherwise forget
who the boss is right and so like I got
some 27y old kid comes to one of my
events he's like give me your
accountabilities what are you going to
do what by 12 months like how will I
know you accomplished what I told you to
accomplish and it landed with me because
that sounds like a question I was asking
back when I was a CEO hiring people but
if you're presidential candidate you got
to remember this is a job inter so I was
like this kid gets it like I'm really
I'm really into that also guys don't
forget about prize picks hurry up and
sign up NFL playoffs is the best time of
the year this is what you got to do I'm
giving you my sing locks first of all
this is a full four player thing so it's
a four player pick so if you hit you can
make you can make some cash off of prize
picks first of all Isaiah Pacho will get
more than 63 and a half rushing yards
Patrick Mahomes will get more than 248 a
half passing yards Travis Kelce I love
you I love what you're doing with Taylor
Swift but I think you're going to get
than 65 receiving yards and Lamar
Jackson MVP I think you're going to get
more than 212 passing yards and sign up
for prize picks.com use that promo code
Schultz they will match your initial
deposit up to $100 so you put in 100 100
for free